[Musique]
ce rendement dizaine de constats de
rester faible tout au centre de tous les
médias
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le pouvoir
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans quel dessein
jeu de cartes est un jeu de cartes le
monde entier nous envie
pas plus qu'un qui l'a 34 secondes yeux
un appel de bill gates qui voulaient
nous l'acheter ce concept la gelée
gentiment renvoyé ce père keith carr le
caire
c'est pas une question d'argent c'est
une question de passion
nous allons jouer ce soir avec monsieur
big flo
wikio bouton quand tu perds ton ronnie
[Applaudissements]
et il faut deux équipes pour jouer quand
même c'est la deuxième équipe qui va
vous ken ce soir j'en suis sûr mais ce
dams est un tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour des gars que je kiffe mais kim fous
rires de ouf n'est pas plus que deux je
vous demande d'aimer
monsieur carlito s'étudie d'accord tu
dis que tu les aimes beaucoup c'est moi
trois vidéos de matchs et carlito alors
le concours d'anecdotes
quand ils se jettent dans les trucs à
fond à chaque fois et le tonnes de
poubelles allumés jetez moi moi je terme
a depuis longtemps une anguille
marseille
[Applaudissements]
alors lequel vous jouez au caire allez
début d'émission
je peux plus eh bien les pompes sauter
et oui vous faites un défi de muscu en
ce moment absolument il a perdu 10 kilos
vous savez tout apparemment ce week-end
c'est la 1ère équipe où j'ai vraiment
des professionnels au lit quand on lui a
proposé l'émission
il m'a dit bon jamais joué au hockey
mais moi c'est quoi ce truc
[Musique]
et ben sylla jamais joué au kent au
regard des règles nous avons quatre
joueurs les deux équipes je vous
distribue les cartes
j'en ai talent 4 milieu de la table et à
montendre vous devez échanger vos quatre
avec celles disposées sur le tapis de
jeu dans le but de réunir 4 cartes
identiques et de le faire savoir à votre
coéquipier sans vous faire choper par
les adversaires
comment le faire savoir à votre équipier
en lui faisant le signe secret sur
lequel vous vous serez mis d'accord ce
dernier cri alors kembs et l'équipe
marque un point mais attention si le
joueur adverse pensent avoir découvert
votre routine secret ils sûrs contre
quel si c'est vrai c'est lui qui marque
un point et le jeu reprend le match se
joue en trois parties l'équipe marquant
le plus de points accède à la grande
finale
donc m à croquer attend ça c'est les
règles ça a fait les règles mais les
vraies règles c'est waouh quel effet et
je vous dis franchement si vous êtes
gentils avec moi un peu sympa et tout il
ya des points en plus qui vont si vous
êtes un peu vénère viaggio elle était 5e
tour et le hibou ton film un point tout
de suite après tout un point tout de
suite fichtrement mais qui tend la main
vite voilà super non plus que son point
g 6 embellie avec le temps ouais
franchement il
fait on rajoute un point tout de suite
mobixell voilà où l'art 10 et
flagornerie c'est un point de
flagorneurs d'accord alors eh bien te
plaît vraiment à quoi encore est ce
qu'on peut avoir un point stop vers le
relais aux cadolles en arrière commencé
et on verra d'études agréable première
partie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
soit un poids beaucoup plus haut point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à bois pour mes qualités au cdp avant de
démarrer cette partie bien sûr vous avez
décidé et mis au préalablement d'accord
sur des signes gens vont pas voir le
signe ici mais les gens chez je pouvoir
bossi tm est le signe pour votre
première partie comme ça va être le
bordel et tout ça va passer inaperçu je
vais dire ils ont triché ils ont triché
a les jambes ce soir mais si j'ai centre
à vue puis 133 domicile sera celui là
c'est bon j'ai le canadien qui l'ont
fait oui non mais pas avec le wat pas
avec le wild
alors on va pas dû à un malaise d'un
mois à touba jeu avec des cartes que
j'ai pris une paix qui delphine d'un cas
d'écart de films
delphine barine assistante de direction
tu te rappelles le 3 quand on a fait la
galette des rois que j'avais fait une
bassine de punch comme un frigo mais
qu'on avait fait une vidéo dans l'eau
qu'à la photocopie ouais ya enfin aller
sur internet sauf un gros buzz je me
reconnais genia ta femme à laquelle je
sais sinon je lui dis j'ai dit jeudi
opposé de la vidéo ouais ouais bah là et
on va jouer avec des émissions de télé
dont le type n'a aucun rapport avec le
programme en question émissions de co2
ses comptes et non j'ai pas côté des
émissions
on va jouer avec danse avec les stars
n'a jamais vu une star dedans mais j'ai
un peu méchant mais c'est marrant mais
c'est pince sans rire quoi voilà tout à
fait c'est second degré nous allons
jouer avec l'amour est dans le pré n'y a
pas d'amour là dedans cela je serais
mort
nous allons jouer avec le millionnaire
je n'ai jamais vu un gîte urbain et à la
20 balles maximum des racines et des
ailes j'ai jamais vu des ailes
j'ai jamais vu des racines pas cette
enquête exclusive des [ __ ] à bangkok
il croit le prouve que c'est exclusif
mais on l'a tous vu lui 500 fois ce
qu'il fait et le dernier strip tease
qu'est-ce que je situe aussi de me
branler dessus jamais refaire il va
évidemment comme branlée il est un peu
que rosicky là vous êtes prêt parce que
nous avons joué avec un autre style de
cartes
on va jouer avec des stars qui nous
apprennent les différents noms des
doigts de la main sans on va jouer avec
robert de niro qui nous apprend le
majeur
c'est drôle daniel craig qui nous
apprend le majeur aussi c'est que ça je
crois cameron diaz qui nous apprend le
majeur de côté parce que je suis sorti
avec un monde où tout le monde surtout
que mme dionne katy perry répartit le
majeur aussi mais plus lent au et
sheeran le majeur a lui même dit john le
seul qui nous apprend tous les autres
doigts
allez on est parti je vous distribuer
quatre cartes chaque rame s'arrête et
pour appeler de vos signes ou pas je
vous distribuer 4 e se dire chaque co
j'ai dit c'est bon j'ai un thème cher à
des jeux comme ça je dirais cette fois
on va voir j'ai déjà les quatre gérer
j'allais quand je vous rappelle que ces
quatre cartes identiques pas de quatre
cartes de la même famille encore car
attention quatre cartes identiques c'est
parti cups l'accepté et je vous dise et
des champions de kembs les quatre c'est
bon j'ai un kuyt rafael contre kyle stop
je vais regarder tu as dit j'ai un ken
n'ont pas pu se syrie a dit qu'outre
quelques pistes et ses salars s'il pense
que tu as quatre quarts pareil je
voudrais rappeler que ces 4 4 4 et d'un
toit
il a d'abord raté ça me tue près c'est
gagné deux points grâce et cinq autres
cage des bobines allemand tu prends deux
points dans la gueule eh ben on va
répéter cette partie nous allons passer
maintenant à la deuxième marque elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tête deuxième pic vous avez convenu
d'un stylo préalable qu'on va voir
maintenant chez vous dans votre coeur
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième partie d'une fois deuxième
signe qu'avez-vous donc tu vous convenu
moi je dis juste ramener comme ça c'est
ça que tu fais il est bien c'était bien
celui-là personne n'a jamais eu ce genre
amis c'est sûr que les deux impossible
qu'ils aient y repère frérot comment à
chaque tour je fais genre je monte mes
cartes comme ça ouais et le dernier
quand je fais les deux tout ça veut dire
que c'est bon c'est pas le dernier quand
tu as un thème si tu veux te pousse à la
faute car tu es tu fasses ya de plus
c'est bon c'est bon ok voici pour notre
deuxième s'il perçoit deuxième partie on
va dégager les émissions de télé et on
va les remplacer par les joueurs de foot
avec des noms pas facile à porter tous
les jours on va jouer avec ulrich le pen
pas facile à porter on va les mêmes là
tout n est pas facile à porter on va
jouer avec marek j'encule offs qui pas
de vanne mais n'ont pas de valve pas de
vannes on joue avec phillip cocu
on va jouer avec jean luc sassus et je
crois que tout le monde le sait en plus
arikado carrés ce mois et dernier
razak ping pong contre ping pong c'est
pas ça doit pas être facile à prendre
on est prêt
[Applaudissements]
mais là non à toi j'ai distribué quatre
cartes regarder comme ça va dire je vous
distribuer 4 k4 garder je m'autorise à
faire et l'udc j'échange mon jeu avec
carlito thébaux c'est très beau alosi il
ya des mecs qui font aurait dû signer
avec le doigt
j'ai déjà un keynes et j'écoute tu
connais son jeu maintenant je pose
quatre cartes au milieu attendait
incarnons on est d'accord tu la deuxième
partie vous vous souvenez de votre
deuxième signe oui c'est bon bien sûr
qu'est ce que la chasse est ouverte aux
enfants rien n'est grave sur ultimate a
pris 3,13
mais quoi attendons les potes autant ya
pas d'attentes âge où on est où là
je suis sûr que ça va être un truc comme
ça votre signe en plus fais gaffe cité
maritime à face à des mal classés le
coût du coup mon appel ça non mais quel
genre post 4 au milieu à tokyo selon mes
calculs exacts je sais très bien faire
qu'il a atteint selon mes calculs deux
points pour celui qui fait que jean qui
lorsqu'il faisait voter contre
gamestop stop à orly tu as dit contre
lequel il a laissé jouer encore attendus
à 10 contre ken donc dans ta tête il a
inquiète mme je vous prends le monde
cette fois n'aura pas dû faire ça
j'espère et c'est perdu
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
internet pour que le tour son compte le
thème sera tat hugo brady il a échangé
nos coeurs ne s'est pas échangé changé
le canon
ouais j'ai pas l'échangé doit mater le
kart wii à la masse des cas oui qu'on a
pas que le livre dégage non on fait ça
c'est la tricherie de prouesses
quelquefois a bien été comptabilisés
comme si le fait qu'on ait livré
n'égalise comptabilisés je voulais dire
pour le contre comme ce raté un point en
plus pour mac flotte de poids j'adore
gagner dans ce livre ce vieux grimoires
ceux répertoriés tous les gages la nuit
les très vieux tous les gages depuis
l'histoire dégage tu peut m'ouvrir ça en
560 à garder cette société qui les
anciens as tu vas perchée tout le monde
à cause de toi ramener la plancha pernal
ça fait mal
[Applaudissements]
ramener la planche infernal on perd les
eaux allaient l'on se gare qu'elle est
inventé merci beaucoup je vous plais ou
sur les cartes modèles sont là moi je
suis d'accord j'ai capté c'est chaud
c'est légal ça non non c'est sa rivale
et nous allons peut être violée après
rejettera attention cup 7 juillet ça
fait mal aussi le calme à temps si c'est
ça mais c'est ouf la science et du
progrès c'était la double truc messieurs
dames et le double creux et dessine
voici un vrai quelle impression
[Applaudissements]
car tout ici vu que le dire ohlala le
cimt et ramzy se faisait cueillir amis
ça fait mal il avait quelques aussi le
80e
[Musique]
les gens ont vu chez eux le signe
c'était ramzi il a fait très mal
c'était quoi votre site mac faye carli
côté le double couche et vous c'était
quoi le site et ramzy il entendait pas
on va voir au ralenti tout de suite
regarde regarde sa massue mcfly du
groupe dans les annales sincèrement
réalisé le plus beau gosse de l'émission
personnes
ça nous fait don instant gueule
maintenant carlitos is big flo rida
allez en fin de partie on sait que trois
gammes d'attenté bonhomme et guy en moi
tu veux faire un petit rap c'est normal
sur le vase et moi la meilleure
rencontre de nos dernières années on les
aime c'est nos amis qui sont réellement
le seul et je les connais un peu ils ont
le chemin de au regard des messages de
flow et a même pas de blague ça va ça va
c'est bon on saisit là cette deuxième
partie c'est moi qui vous imposer le
site celui là la troisième partie c'est
moi qui vous impose le signe tombe sur
toi même en le disant mais bon pote la
troisième partie c'est moi qui nous
impose le signe et le signe sera ou deux
aiguilles xavier dupont de ligonnes
utilisions les durs votre signe il faut
placer xavier dupont de ligonnès fait
marrer mais il faut la placer celle là
ok je dirais de nom de jean horrible à
chaque tour et qu'on dirait xavier
dupuis de news de lui d'ailleurs miné
depuis sa dernière partie on va dégager
les wad et on va rajouter les featurings
improbable où on va jouer avec mireille
mathieu et patrick de filles dans tout
cas d'un oui a strong et patrick duffy
s'était déjà un acteur dans dallas ok
c'est vrai film oui c'est des vrais
disques vraiment c'est vraiment défiguré
qu'ils ont fait mireille mathieu elle a
fait ça avec un acteur de dallas à
l'époque on va jouer avec chuck berry et
dorothée conférence entre dorothée est
fait mention et chuck berry des
références pour les pierre palmade et
jean michel jarre j'te flash je te
l'offre
c'est vrai dit il devrait aller le
chercher et j'y tiens on va jouer avec
la fouine et patrick bruel
les faucheurs il s'appelle jeu d'enfant
le son est plutôt bien dedans sans bravo
merci m points
non on va jouer avec doc gynéco et
bernard classique
est ce que vous le connaissez ce dernier
l'a larusso et bwin oui oui
[Musique]
je vais distribuer les quatre cartes à
chacun si vous réunissez les quatre
cartes identiques
vous gagnez le 14 j'ai la carte big
jolies photos rares san jose
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[ __ ] aux liégeois dans ta totec à lui
seul ça va je suis dès que je déteste
perdre la faute est habitué mais moi je
suis pas habitué
on perd mais fier tu me fais de moi je
me remmy des malfaiteurs l'insolent
[Musique]
attendait la dernière partie est à 1000
points le dernier signe je voulais
imposer tous les spectateurs les
connaissent vous réunissez 4k de
footballeurs ou de featurings je vous
rappelle que c'est maintenant que tout
joue celui qui perd ibères notre signé
nous c'était de dire le monde quelqu'un
de connu oh hé bien joué cette technique
patrick balkany l'a bien jouer encore ça
mais c'est horrible s'ils font que du
fait qu on peut pas refaire des cartes
avec xavier dupont de ligonnès que comme
ça qu'est ce
voilà
[Applaudissements]
oh
attendons quand on voit comment vérifier
un corner qu'ils avaient une très bonne
mise de départ
gentil on va gérer ces nos origines
attends je peux boire votre cap de kent
je peux voir ton cap
je vais jeter la balle il faut qu'on le
montre aux gens quand même voir arriver
vite ce qu'aime c'est un mec c'est le
public le plus que nous avons eu plus
alors attendez qu'elle était le signe
est ce que tu peux bien pas que tu peux
me dire quel était le fruit on peut dire
c'est parce que c'est elle c'est que
j'allais dire quoi xavier dupont de
ligonnès qui me l'a dit et tu l'as dit
et tu as joué très bien dit partout on
peut revendre
ne croyez pas tellement c'était tôt
c'était très tôt voilà superlatifs
est-ce que je peux connaître le score de
cette dernière plusieurs mois le score
est donc de 6 et c'est une victoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je dis pas à donner vous avez gagné 1000
axis bravo c'est une raclée
vous avez gagné le droit de jouer la
grande finale infernale or mais chaque
grande finale ya des cadeaux qu'allez
vous gagnez vous allez voir le choix
entre deux cadeaux on va voir tout de
suite le premier cadeau que vous pouvez
gagner maintenant qu'il est rentré dans
l'adolescence votre iphone vous cause du
souci
il fait du camping avec des mets de
blizzard il fréquente des femmes de
petite vertu
ils planquent même des trucs bizarres ce
sont les c'est vraiment pas bien mon
iphone non non non la solution la prison
pour iphone grâce à la prise d'eau pour
iphone sur votre téléphone retrouvera
enfreint le droit chemin
merci prison pour un critère décalé et
décalé c'est d'humour assez joué à l'eau
sans que c'est l'humour absurde et
loufoque harper lui a tant ils ont gagné
1000 points à 6 mais on en a gagné deux
manches à une
bon mais c'est bon le deuxième cadeau il
ya un deuxième cadeau pour ceux qui
n'ont pas d'iphone
bon oui gagner une barbe on en avait une
à gagner la palme orient mais tu peux
gagner un livre sublime thème la
littérature mais j'adore ça c'est
regarder ça se regarde toulouse
interdite d'elie semoun
c'est un vrai humour ista la ville il
devient très sérieux quand il s'agit de
choisir ses plantes et d'aménager son
jardin lui même impatient il préfère
apprendre de ses erreurs plutôt que
d'écouter les conseils et bien cassé
rêveur et contemplatif
il n'hésite pas à prendre la pioche
quand il décide de créer un nouveau
bassin le livre de chevet de tout
humoristes en herbe la bible de la vanne
horticole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la venue dans la grande finale à berlin
monsieur est un test vous avez gagné un
jeu basé sur la complicité
vous avez bien ken les deux autres bravo
on va voir maintenant oms et les pauvres
ça va la loose recherche de vidéos
messieurs je vais vous poser dix
questions à chacun à tour de rôle
si vous avez cette réponse identique ça
veut dire vraiment que vous êtes non
seulement des complices notamment des
frères mais aussi des âmes soeurs les
jeunes du plq du permis la d2 le couple
est appelée à l'évasion litois lyonnais
je vais prendre le temps et non aura que
30 secondes est ce qu'il ya vraiment eu
il ya eu des coups de fil des réunions
en proposant cette émission fou d'aller
voir les gars de canal tu leur as dit on
va jouer à kembs fin au début idiot pas
trop trop cru et ouvre quand même mais
ils ont fait confiance et regarde mes
braves oui attention toi on a le temps
de répondre d'accord ces dix questions
pour savoir plus sur notre pire tu étais
la loose tabac
j'aime bien être là non oui c'est
martine de niro pacino pacino sérieux
salamé salami qui me plaisent ou sucrés
ou salés sa salle et j'aimerais moi
aussi bien sûr la famille on est bien
présent tout ça les allées et trouvera
au canada parce que ce n'est pas
vraiment victor hugo ou hugo boss
j'étais plus ça pour plus tôt elie
semoun dorego victor hugo ps je dis ça
pour les meufs t es 20es bao fifa 20,6
favin la famille ça aurait été mieux
avec nous les plus chauds ouais mais
c'est pas vous
corbeau ou renard corbeau loquet fièvre
du samedi soir ou gueule de bois du
dimanche matin fièvre du samedi soir
chez soi ça staff ça se tape débat soit
[Applaudissements]
start up nation ou stand up nation
réponse des nations
cet arrêt pourrait manger tellement vite
en letton vadims j'ai gagné voir blondes
ou brunes breen toujours bernard menez
ou pierre ménès je vais appeler que
c'est le propre de pierre ménage c'est
même plus qui c'est le premier attention
celle là j'en suis un peu fier
reconstruire notre dame vous
reconstruire la voix de garantie donc là
ouais sainté futuna ppe des retraités
loup garou non je pense que c'est bien
de reconstruire notre dame et mon avis
c'est que c'est pas forcément obligé de
reproduire à l'identique je pense que un
bâtiment il évolue avec ce ailleurs ils
devront refléter aussi la soirée super
bercy c'est dur voire impossible la
tuque est à 30 secondes situe à cette
réponse identique que ton frère
c'est la preuve que vous êtes vraiment
des frères sinon y voit là on a compris
on est prêt le coût d'un vrai parti de
niro pacino devenir occupent sont sucrés
ou salés sucrés victor hugo basse métaux
rigoureuse d'actifs à 20
il fallait un corbeau renard corbeau
fièvre du samedi soir aux gueules de
bois du dimanche matin fièvre du samedi
soir start up nation stand up nation
stand up blonde ou brune brune bien
bernard menez ou pierre ménès il connaît
pas bien pierre ménès recontre
reconstruire notre dame ou reconstruire
la voix de garou et l'a dit notre dame
[Musique]
attend attend un collier la caméra d'or
[Applaudissements]
tous les ponts
souviens toi
accident va surtout à venir va pas venir
au papa lui dépensé d'anti
[Applaudissements]
tous
willow est en lui offrant comme dans
tout le bronze au relais du dernier rien
ne nous fait pas besoin de retard
ensuite notre langue et game tôt
les neuf ans sur youtube lui vient tous
les immenses et en live tous les
mercredis et m
sortir et bien l'auto guy delcourt déchu
ben ali
jean marie delphine dard ou et voilà où
merci à tous à très bientôt
et surtout allez tous vous faire caisse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ban
un costume de presse